Will Ferrell's joining us here in the
studio always great to see you will came
bearing gifts
and he brought in anchorman underwear
for all of the damn heads it's the it's
the great stocking stock do you have a
bunch of stuff at your house I do I have
a swag a swag closet you know in in in
the garage where there's a eclectic
collection of various things what would
I be surprised at that's in the swag
closet at the Will Ferrell compound you
would be very surprised at a couple of
time X watches from the movie stranger
than fiction
the watch was featured in the movie and
they made they made a collector's
edition watch they thought was gonna be
huge
didn't quite take off if the movie had
taken off the watch might have taken off
you know it was celebrated critically
but was that a film or a movie that was
a film nobody makes money in film no no
exactly
Timex did not make any money in that
but tighty-whities you can't go wrong
with that no comedy white blue and and
Fritzie what color you again I got a
nice red one nice red one as a special
does it happen these are called beard of
Zeus blue beards blue yeah is there a
title for the red that would be a sex
panther red and I believe the the the
sticker price is still on there they
retail for about ten bucks
oh you're selling yourself short yeah
not bad anyway still not available in
stores never avail it says unique why
front fly oh yeah a lot of design
meetings would you have to go and try
them on then come out in front of a
group of people a boardroom like what do
you think Tess market yeah yep yep need
more of that they look at me through a
two-way like online yeah exactly
I fritzy a did his stand-up act last
night yes I heard did you ever do the
Comedy Store I don't think I ever did
the comp no I might have done a sketch
some sketch comedy at The Comedy Store
because you were you ever considered a
stand-up comedian I tried to buy was not
I tried it for a year and a half in fact
Fritzi and I were having a very
enlightened conversation in the hallway
of how yeah I tried it it is the single
hardest thing to do in terms of the
comedy art forms and that's why I fled
to sketch comedy but yeah I had I had I
had my stand-up act and I did I think
that the Icehouse I did the improv I did
a lot of the LA places and uh but I so I
admired that you you went up there
appreciate that yeah yeah okay the first
joke didn't go well and there was
technical issues the microphone
technical in terms of actually yet
working yeah like the microphone
yeah okay so this is the second they
tuned you out
second joke first one didn't go over
well okay and here is the second joke
last night for Fritzi what's my wife on
the rare occasion that we're intimate
and I'm on top she can use a you know me
having a few less lb I keep waiting for
her to take a yellow flag and pull it
out of her and it's basically roughing
the spouse I think like the NFL has that
now where they protect the quarterback
so you know you can't put the full body
weight on on the quarterback so I don't
need to put my full body weights on the
on the wife you got to kind of tilt to
the side or you get a penalty so you
lose real quickly if you have to like
while you're having sex do that so it's
not great okay so now audio seems great
on that one you're talking about that
the audience
yeah they heard that one and they heard
it yeah they did yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah it's hard it's hard to do but what
about the joke good stuff what about the
comedy of it
okay here's here's the next C you're too
nice well I mean it sounded a little
Henny Youngman ish Henny Youngman
starting but he went my wife take me
loot now you went blue early and I told
you if you go blue don't go yeah exactly
that's a tough exactly but did you go
blue because they didn't react to your
opener no that was just that my plan was
inflammatory bowel disease sleep apnea
paper alright this is when Fritzi
started to win over the audience the
crowd warmed up a little bit to Fritzi
with this joke went to Israel anybody
had been to Israel Tel Aviv Jerusalem
and all that so my biggest concern even
though I wanted to see kibbutz ooze and
try shwarma and some of the weird
Mediterranean food was to make sure we
had two separate rooms so the wife and I
got free but we have a little intimacy
it'd be nice so I spent the extra money
got two rooms one for the kids and my
wife and I nothing so I don't know what
move is exactly what are you doing what
do you mean what am i doing we can do
something unholy in the holy land of
surprise okay oh wow yeah okay yeah
bringing him in those are real laughs
right there was where those who were
solid actual more than one person
laughing time microphone worked yeah
technically and then you did about 30
more seconds thing wrap so he had five
minutes there at the Communists five
minutes is very hard to to do in the
sense that I mean you got a you know
yeah no it was definitely challenging I
was nervous as as we were talking
earlier as we were going along you know
you start getting more relaxed because
there's not much less
have to remember to say and you feel
like you're getting them just relaxed
when they give you the light and say get
off the stage yes who's the comedian you
saw and you went I either want to do it
or I can't do it no you will I don't
care about Fritzi I well we were talking
III was I was a little bit conversation
you guys had you know during the
commercial bonded he needs to read the
the book that Steve Martin wrote which
is is based on his whole career it talks
about you know he started doing he grew
up in Garden Grove which is right next
to Disneyland and after high school his
high school job was to work in the magic
shop where he learned like sleight of
hand and he would the beginnings of his
comedy roots where he'd play his banjo
and the stage shows and that sort of
thing and it just shows how someone like
Steve Martin who seemed so off-the-cuff
and so natural and so silly and just
where does he come up we was it was
calculated to the second and Robin
Williams was like that - absolutely the
impression that it was wholly improv but
they he talks about in the book
technically where he's you know he's
already thinking three jokes ahead while
he's in the middle of his joke and and
that was that was the one guy who you
know I remember getting his listen to
his albums and just thinking oh this
this type of thinking is is just
something I'd love to love to get close
to even but then there's more of a
performance to Steve Barr yeah you know
what you you know your your your traits
your it's my dream yeah yes yeah my
physical attribute yes yes that you're a
physical comedian I'm so I can make
anything funny I mean right out of the
gate
does your wife think you're funny she
will occasionally say you know what you
still got it
that's it yeah
so that's the what would she be honest
with you uh no she I think she would
just go okay humor get hurt like that
show you first yeah like you get you got
her by being funny yeah yeah I said she
doesn't think you're funny
no no she I think she you know she still
does she's used to the funny oh yeah
okay yeah she's used to when I one of
the things where I I was able to kind of
capture her I had a I had a flowers
delivered to her every day of the week
at her work beautiful flowers but the
cards would say things like I hope
you're having a great day work I think
about you often but remembered everyone
hates you or the next day be like you're
you're very pretty but you're not as
pretty as your coworker Marissa just
little and it's dangerous she thought it
was hilarious and I was in yeah but if
you did that now oh yeah I still are you
doing every Mother's Day I try to mix it
up here I think the latest one was my my
heart flutters when I think of you it
could be love it could be my atrial
fibrillation
how about greeting cards greeting cards
I haven't written a greeting card to her
in a long time but you could do a
business oh I could yeah I could yeah I
could I could hire inflammatory bowel
disease they do he's a Will Ferrell
Jonas you didn't have anything to
promote today did you
well I've got a Christmas Day we've got
a movie coming out is that Sherlock
Holmes and Watson john c reilly and
myself as Sherlock Holmes and Doctor
John Watson so
they'll be in theaters how's your action
that's much-anticipated now did you did
you purposely have a bad accident no
well no I purposely had a good accident
it will be determined by the audience's
let me let me hear a little bit of
Sherlock Holmes's well Sherlock Holmes
is accent I did I did kind of a print a
little bit of a accentuated accent based
on the performances of Jeremy Britt
which was a BBC variation of the show
Sherlock Holmes so there it is here's my
accent wow I can't wait till Christmas
yes I can't wait I can't wait I you know
I was also thinking about this so this
is the 15 year anniversary of elf yes
and old school right I think so those
were back-to-back for you does that
sound right back to back to back it was
uh it was old school elf and anchorman
no boy yeah that's the Holy Trinity
that's pretty good right there come get
some of this yeah and then I saw where
people keep asking about you to do a
sequel to elf and I remember you telling
us that you thought you may have thrown
away your career often yeah the
originals but the original yeah that was
a that there were moments where yeah
running around an elf suit and you know
New York City thinking oh boy well it
was fun while it lasted and this will
either be a Christmas classic or you
know one of my last movies but out of
those three which one did you say I know
you're apprehensive so that was that was
such a pleasant surprise okay but
anchorman you knew was gonna be a hit an
old school you knew be a hit
no all three had no idea the only the
only you know the only one I mean old
school we had it we had a really good
time filming it it it felt you know kind
of fresh and different but
I really didn't know and old you know
anchorman was was so hard to get made
there it was very tough to commit
studios to make a comedy about the
newsroom and when they finally kind of
gave us the green light based on the
success of elf
then you know we really we really were
felt like we were playing with the
houses money to get to make that movie
but but you know once again it was you
know the screening process though if elf
wasn't successful anchorman might not
have been made exactly yeah there wasn't
yeah yeah
so yeah DreamWorks was holding on to
that that script and an old school the
actually the success of old school led
to because I was filming elf while old
school came out how many takes with the
beer bong scene in old school I was
there beer there's a non-alcoholic beer
okay yeah okay yeah how many takes later
there was real
by the time I'm on stage with Snoop Dogg
there was you'd been drinking there
there'd been some real beer one or two
yeah but uh how many takes with with the
beer bong yeah I who knows who knows but
is that the script like did you go as
scripted in the beer bongs
the the beer bongs all of that it tastes
so good when it hits your like that that
just came off the cuff and had bath neon
and all that stuff I was just like I
think was just I drink a beer bong and
then go start partying with kids but so
I just kind of came up with all that but
guys will use that line you know it's
pretty nice little Saturday yeah yeah
like we've all done that with our wives
like what are you doing today uh-huh
you know I'm gonna go to Bed Bath &
Beyond and it just felt like what that
guy would say trying to relate to kids
yeah in that moment is there any part of
it's like are you Frank can you relate
to him at all I don't go to Bed Bath &
Beyond you do no no I'm not a I'm not a
do-it-yourselfer yeah people who do that
for you I I don't have people
I you know Amazon right okay yeah but
where do you go that I would people be
surprised where you just CVS right okay
yeah just really have a CVS card I do
see I don't I refuse to get one but do
you you just go to hang out or like what
I would see go and get some vitamins
yeah oh you will yeah and pick up
prescriptions yeah but you get some
floss do people say anything to you
occasionally yeah but they've security
guard knows me I know do they say like
be fun do you ever get that hey say
something funny not usually
yeah same with fridge yeah yeah they
don't do that sorry I'm sorry we're
going to take a break here you said okay
I think it's great
okay you have any more comedy should we
play should we go out on one of fritzy's
Joe do we have any more now that's it oh
that was it alright Fritzie do you have
anything for a will that we could like
left over what what didn't make the set
last night you want to go back to
section row seat
do we have okay anything from Caroline's
okay okay pretty are you okay with this
good bad ugly it's that's it's he's
taking an interest in my amateur comedy
career and that's extremely flattered
yeah see I think one of the best things
the show could do actually is if we
follow the arc of Todd's career here he
started with section row seat a joke
that absolutely bombed and then you can
make it into a really good joke that end
by the time yep you could see the growth
of Todd as a comic and be like looking
with the shadow and now it's awesome now
it crushes right hmm alright well we'll
play that that hobble that altogether
that was that was his big joke that was
his opener Caroline so when Fritzi was
at Caroline's and what is it again
section row what is called a teeth no no
I'm the host yeah
it's called I know why listen to the big
man here alright
when we come back more with your barrel
so will Pharaoh who lived at home until
he was 24 Zarah easy
no is it factually that's true okay what
was it like to be so you graduated from
college and you're living at home right
yet your bedroom right what was in your
bedroom
uh what was in my bedroom I think it was
pretty sad I don't think there were any
posters on the wall cuz you know are you
gonna put posters up till you're 12 or I
mean you're back home so what's more
embarrassing yeah posters up you're
living at home yeah well yeah but I
think still having posters up on the
wall anyway they were just blank walls
mounts and maybe an Ikea bookcase empty
no books yeah that's about it
well working as a bank teller how trying
to do stand-up comedy how good were you
as a bank teller uh first couple days
were disastrous agenda but I don't know
we might have talked about this before
have we talked about yeah I was first
day I was I think $300 short and the
manager came over and she said huh
that's weird you know what don't worry
you know
Joe over here was 300 over so you guys
must have you probably traded money at
some point I just went yeah we probably
did I was like I didn't talk to Joe all
day and then day two eyes I balanced out
my drawer and I was this bizarre this
odd number I was like to 287 and 93
cents short she's like what's going on
like I have no idea I really don't but
then from that point on clear sailing
yeah yeah yeah yeah killed it killed it
all right
this is section row seat this is last
year Caroline's and fritzy goes on stage
and this is his opening quote unquote
joke okay so I'm at a sporting event the
other night
and at least three different people come
over to me asking if I'm sitting in
their seats so I don't know if it's a
few guys ever deal with this if you go
to a concert or sporting events how
difficult is to [ __ ] seats and
concert or a sporting event think about
it it's got all the information you need
right there on the ticket section row
seat number section row see number it's
really really not that complicated
I've got these people coming over to me
and saying I think we're in the same
thing not only they not in my seats
they're all the way on the other side of
they really couldn't have been further
from where I'm at so I don't understand
section row seat let's let's get it
together just some people I just can't
deal with that yes that that was it I
love the premise we all do we can all
relate to and then it just didn't quite
yeah you're at the base camp there for
Mount Everest the peanut gallery
suggested it had it there had to be some
kind of way of bringing I was really
excited to see where I was gonna go and
it really literally went nowhere I was
in the wrong scene I guess there's maybe
a way to bring it back or like it turned
out that I was in the wrong seat all
along or something but it needs
something that's more Oh seat or or that
you were confused that that's that's an
actual seat section row seat I don't
know see I can't even figure it out yeah
well you're not a stand-up comedian no
I'm not thank god it's a little it's
highbrow humor yeah yeah you did do your
kids go do they expect you to be able to
get seats for sporting events we
unfortunately they do yeah I'll have a
lot of arguments and you got your soccer
kid on so obviously the yeah good seats
are used to to to sitting in nice seats
and so it is fun to switch it up on them
and just you know sit in normal seats
where and then the argument is like are
you sure we're not in Italy but dad did
you check
did you make the appropriate calls are
you sure we're not in a suite I'm like
I'm sure look look at this look at it
says section row see that's how it's
done
yeah you did it you didn't uh the only
thing is you have to have previous
knowledge to get it to the joke though
they bombed no for that to work
well it's it's great to see you you
didn't wear the old school tennis shoes
wait no did I I thought you were
bringing did I show up in my bike shorts
last year on York in New York yes not
here now that's where I got confused
yeah were you oh you were gonna we were
talking backstage that last time I came
on the show it was in New York I was
thinking last time I came here
yeah left nothing to the imagination no
smuggling grapes out of the country
right there's what you owe mr. more like
more like tangelos it's great to see you
great to see it in the music means
you're gone you're that's it it's it I
got it I got to get out of York right
now right now for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]